do you see regulations still being a
hurdle for a lot of these organizations
it's just a fact that the biggest
organizations across the globe need that
regulatory determinism they need some of
the rules of the game so they can add to
the value of the game but what I'd say
is right now so get ready everyone there
readying themselves right they are
acting as if there was regulation in
terms of the preparation the
connectivity understanding the product
coming up with the structures right I
can name probably six of the largest
banks in the world who if if and when
they get the green for go sign I think
they can be active throughout all the
markets in crypto within a month they're
readying themselves but they do need
those approvals be it the cftc the SEC
or the fed I'm hopeful and I'm expectant
that we will get there but look we're
going to be impatient in crypto land
we're probably going to expect it this
year we're not going to see it this year
I'd like to see there'd be some I'd like
to think there'd be some sign of
regulated determinism in 2023 I think
will be much much closer if I had to bet
the floodgates
to true institutionalization of crypto
will be 2024 and the key that opens or
unlocks those floodgates will be
regulation that is understandable and is
built on the key pillars that currently
exist within traditional Finance